It's now time for our next game,
Hidden Talent Ranch.
Cracked.com is one
of those rare comedy Web sites
that's actually funny. They
recently posted a great article
about celebrities
with surprising hidden talents.
For instance, did you know
that Willie Nelson has
a fifth-degree black belt
in tae kwon do?
Or that Jet Ski champion
Vanilla Ice
also was a rapper at one point?
Well, now you do. Comedians,
I'm gonna show you a picture
of a celebrity.
I would like you to tell me
what their secret talent is.
First up, Skrillex.
Yes, Andrew.
Works at Claire's boutique
at the mall.
Yes, points!
Next up, Channing Tatum.
-Ben.
-Styling Jonah Hill's back hair.
Points.
Next up, the Olsen twins. Adam.
Uh, appearing at the end
of a hallway
when you're riding
your big wheel.
Oh. Flawless reference.
Points. Next up, Nicki Minaj.
Secret talent. Adam.
(bleep)ing.
Points.
Next up, Ellen. Ellen DeGeneres.
Andrew.
Huge ivory collection.
Points. You wouldn't know it.
-You wouldn't know it.
It's a secret. -It's a surprise.